well in order to write about the
emotional state of a character I have to
get as close as possible to being in
that emotional state so I have to get
that sad I have to get that happy that
crazed that bizarre that obsessed you
know whatever one of my characters are
going through I have to find my way into
it you know it's just it's just the way
I do it
there's a story in this book called The
Ballad of Paul nonetheless where he
becomes so obsessed with pop music and
so obsessed with his iPod and that he he
you know every thought he has this can
becomes directly related to a song so I
went that far into it I tried to talk
only in song lyrics you know whenever
anybody was talking to me I drove my
friends and family mad because whenever
they would talk to me you know I would
say well that reminds me of this you
know a Rolling Stone song or whenever
anybody said something accidentally that
was a lyric or a title of a song I would
then sing the song so it was crazy but
it got me seeing the way it was
completely alienating my friends and
family really got me to a place where I
could write that story about this really
genial guy who's actually very much an
antihero